ameerin gotta me also known as a temp an
ostomy or temp anatomy is a surgical
procedure to remove fluid in the middle
ear and re-establish equal air pressure
on both sides of the eardrum
the ear consists of three main parts the
outer ear the middle ear and the inner
ear the outer ear includes the pinna
which collects sound waves and the ear
canal which transports sound waves to
the eardrum a paper-thin layer of tissue
separating the outer and middle ear
sound waves caused the eardrum to
vibrate which in turn vibrates three
tiny bones inside the middle ear called
the malleus incus
and stay peace which pass the sound
vibrations along to the inner ear the
inner ear translates vibrations into
electrical signals which are picked up
by the auditory nerve sent to the brain
and interpreted as sound this complex
process occurs instantly allowing us to
hear the sounds around us as they have
been for the eardrum to vibrate properly
the air pressure in the middle ear must
be at the same level of pressure as air
outside the ear air enters the middle
ear through the eustachian or auditory
tube when you yawn and hear a pop your
eustachian tube has just carried an air
bubble to your middle ear to equalize
the pressure
infection allergy mass or enlarged
adenoids can block the eustachian tube
allowing fluid to collect in the middle
ear fluid prevents the eardrum from
vibrating properly blocking normal
transmission of sound through the middle
ear which may cause hearing loss in some
instances the fluid may become infected
with bacteria resulting in otitis media
or ear infection
reasons for performing amiran gotta me
include draining ear fluid trapped in
the ear for more than three months
treating chronic ear infections not
cleared up with antibiotics restoring
hearing loss caused by fluid buildup
preventing delays in speech development
due to hearing loss in children or
testing fluid from the middle ear for
bacteria
before the procedure an intravenous line
will be started in most cases general
anesthesia is used to put the patient to
sleep for the duration of the procedure
the surgeon will make a small incision
in the eardrum using a scalpel or laser
and drain the fluid in the middle ear
in many cases the surgeon will place a
ventilation tube or PE tube through the
incision this small tube will drain any
fluid that collects after surgery and
allow air into the middle ear to help
dry it out
if necessary the surgeon will repeat the
procedure on the opposite ear the entire
procedure takes 30 to 60 minutes the
incision in the eardrum will heal itself
so no stitches are required
after surgery the patient will go to the
recovery room for monitoring children
may be fussy after their procedure and
should be encouraged to eat and drink
anything they can tolerate if your child
has pain avoid aspirin and instead use
acetaminophen at an age specific dose if
additional pain relief is necessary your
doctor can recommend other options the
PE tube usually falls out on its own
within several months